[Music]
innovation at work is an online
education resource that enables anyone
to bring design thinking to their
workplace in this three-part workshop
series Stanford d.school
experts will guide you and your team
through proven exercises and techniques
that will spark new ideas tackle your
projects creatively and solve real
business challenges it doesn't matter
which industry you work in or what your
role is if you're interested in a
culture of innovation this is a tool for
you getting started is easy even if you
have zero experience and design thinking
to get started
one enroll yourself online only you need
to register and purchase access for your
group to invite a group of 4 to 18
colleagues to participate 3 pick a date
and make sure everyone is available for
2 to 3 hours 4 find an open meeting
space for the workshop so people can get
out of their chairs and do real work
together 5 log in to your account ahead
of time to review materials and you're
ready to go on the day of the workshop
you play the role of the catalyst 1
bring your computer with internet
connection and log into your account to
access the videos to set up a projector
to play the workshop videos for your
group as the catalyst you facilitate
press play handout the materials and
make sure everyone participates the
videos will guide you all through the
workshop activities so there's no
pressure 3 encourage positive energy and
an open mind so that your group really
gets motivated to collaborate innovate
and problem-solve
these workshops are all about embedding
Design Thinking principles to your
everyday work get ready to come with
questions and leave inspired
you